there are a lot of reasons why Stephen
King's it was ripe for a rival on screen
in 2017 it been 27 years since the last
adaptation which is a fateful number in
the story
clowns are still pretty damn scary and
well the 1990 TV mini-series simply
couldn't capture the most terrifying
elements of Kings bestseller and the
network restrictions and a small screen
budget the outdated special effects in
particular have rendered certain
portions of the original eight film
laughable instead of frightening even so
there are certain scenes in the 1990
miniseries that still hold up and
they're actually even scarier than the
new big-screen adaptation the moving
pictures the 2017 version of eights
includes a memorably terrifying sequence
in which Pennywise comes to life within
a sinister slide show but the 1990
version of that moment is a bit area in
some respects billed n bro is alone and
still completely grief-stricken about
his brother Georgie's funeral when he
first comes into contact with it
he skims her a book of photos when all
of a sudden Georgie's most recent
picture winks to him and starts oozing
blood what's worse is a bill's parents
are more concerned about him not
belonging in the room than finding out
what he saw or more importantly what
they can't see
it's my marish enough not to be believed
or heard by your parents but when
they're smearing invisible blood all
over your murdered brother's room it's
even worse
Pennywise is page bouncing also comes
into play later on when the losers look
at Mike's dad's photo album about
dairies many shout murder sprees and the
town squares carnival comes to life with
a certain dancing clown at the center
if the slow burn of him coming into
closer full-color view isn't scary
enough the fact that he then reaches
through the page to grab at the losers
should keep you up at night Ben's father
the new version of it makes very little
of Ben hanscom's background but the
miniseries introduces a Naurang elements
of the story that still works as a hair
raiser early on Ben is seen traipsing
through the Barrens alone and sees his
long-lost father in full military dress
standing in the swamp and beckoning him
into the sewer the 2017 movie offers its
own share of Pennywise as dread inducing
impressions but the idea that Ben's dead
dad would slowly morph into the clown
like that is a kind of creepy cruelty
that's hard to
at Beverly's bathroom the 2017 movie
does a good job of depicting Beverly
Marcia's infamous bloody bathroom her
physical maturation is stoking fear in
Beverly and others in her life but
there's still something extraordinarily
unsettling about the 1990 version it's
slower there are children's voices
crying out to Beverly and once the
balloon of blood explodes all over the
place mr. Marsh puts his hand right into
the gory mess unable or unwilling to see
what his kid sees so it's a test of a
squeamishness and sanity
Eddie's shower there's no denying that
Eddie Kaz brags first encounter with it
in the 2017 version is really creepy but
there's a certain emotional
vulnerability that's lost in translation
from the first in the first version
Eddie is being pinballed by the adults
in his life his mother has told him not
to shower at school but his gym teacher
absolutely insists he does everyone else
has already cleaned up by the time coat
wins the argument which leaves Eddie out
to dry solo in the school showers just
as they start to come to life mid rinse
all the nozzles start operating
themselves and turn every spout into a
scolding torture device meant to steer
Eddie away from safety
just before Pennywise pays him a visit
through the drain if psycho didn't make
you think twice about showering away
from home he is another scene that will
creep into your memory at the worst
moment going clear the kid's final stand
against Pennywise in the new film is
incredibly similar to what goes down in
the miniseries and have both ignore the
novel's very weird ritual absurd in
favor of a more old-fashioned fight with
it and make their pact to come back
together if and when it returns but
despite all the false to be found on the
camerawork props and the visual effects
the 1990 version is still highly
effective thanks to some key fog machine
work and the attack on poor Stan while
the losers are trying to stay together
Pennywise already sees the weakest links
in their chain and tries to make a meal
out of Stanley URIs it's a terrible
preview of what's to come and the fact
that Pennywise is able to break their
chain
certainly undermines their sense of
strength in numbers
in return the meta element one of the
essential elements of the first movie is
how informative pop culture was to the
loser sphere for example within days of
the group seeing I was a teenage
werewolf at the Paramount Theater the
group's most entertainment oriented
member Richie Tozier is chased through
the school's basement by a werewolf in a
varsity jacket that scene speaks volumes
about Stephen King story and influences
as it derives from so many other scares
while also informing new nightmares all
its own
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out with his cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]